Iskandar Widjaja hat viele Gesichter.
Und Schubladendenken mag er weder
in der Musik noch im Leben.
Der Berliner mit indonesischen Wurzeln ist
ein Ausnahmegeiger,
der immer wieder auch abseits der Klassik
nach Inspirationen sucht.
Aber so extravagant er auch wirkt: Für ihn
zählt allein die Musik.
Letztendlich machen wir Musik,
weil wir Leute berühren wollen
und weil wir sie bewegen wollen.
Und weil wir in uns einen Punkt
erreichen wollen,
wo wir selber so berührt sind auf der Bühne,
dass wir die anderen auch damit bewegen
können.
Anders geht‘s nämlich nicht.
Indonesien. Die Heimat seiner Eltern besucht
Iskandar Widjaja regelmäßig.
Hier ist der 32-Jährige ein Star.
Auftritte in Werbeclips und TV-Shows
haben ihn
in dem asiatischen Inselstaat berühmt
gemacht.
Hier spielt er in den großen Konzerthäusern
wie im vergangenen Jahr in Jakarta
bei dieser Benefizgala für Tsunami-Opfer.
Ich hab‘ eine Zeit lang diesen Spagat
versucht,
Popstar in Indonesien, Klassikkünstler in
Deutschland.
Und seit ein, zwei Jahren hab‘ ich mich
entschieden:
Es gibt mich nur noch als Gesamtpaket.
Auch wenn ich in Indonesien mit Frack
spiele und für den Präsidenten spiele,
versuche ich immer, mir selbst treu zu bleiben
und so authentisch wie möglich
rüberzukommen.
Auftritt in einem Kölner Club.
Hier spielt Iskandar Widjaja nicht nur
klassische Musik:
Das Programm reicht von
Johann Sebastian Bach
bis zu einer Coverversion des Hits
„Chandelier“ von Popstar Sia.
Mich sprechen plötzlich Stücke an,
und da unterscheide ich eben nicht,
ist das jetzt dieses oder das Genre.
Und genau das möchte ich auch in meinen
Konzerten erreichen.
Ich möchte diese Unterteilung aufbrechen.
Ich möchte, dass Leute, die in mein Konzert
kommen, wissen: Es gibt alles.
So wie er in seiner Musik ganz
unterschiedliche Sachen probiert,
spielt Iskandar Widjaja auch gerne mit
verschiedenen Images.
Nicht nur bei Fotoaufnahmen.
Ich ziehe auf der Bühne gerne Outfits an,
die irgendwie meinen Interpretationsansatz
unterstreichen.
Und das kann wirklich sehr variieren.
Von extrem schlicht, einfarbig nur in Schwarz,
total reduziert,
auf total over-the-top.
Weil genau das ist das, was mich auch an der
Musik interessiert.
Mit vier Jahren beginnt Iskandar Widjaja,
Geige zu spielen,
inspiriert von seinem Großvater,
einem Komponisten.
Nach einem Geigenstudium in Berlin hat er
keine Lust auf die üblichen Wettbewerbe.
Er spielt lieber direkt bei
Weltklasse-Dirigenten
wie Zubin Mehta vor und überzeugt.
Demo-Aufnahmen für das nächste Album.
Darauf soll es einen bunten Stilmix geben.
Unter anderem experimentieren die Musiker
mit einem Stück
des italienischen Barock-Komponisten Pietro
Antonio Locatelli.
Iskandar Widjaja: in Indonesien ein Star,
in vielen Welten zu Hause.